it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning a winter flu warning england's
deputy chief medical officer said we
should prepare for a big surge in flu
cases medical experts are warning that
hospital admissions from coronavirus flu
and other respiratory illnesses could
double compared to a normal year but
there is some good news travel agents
are expecting a large increase in
half-term bookings after the number of
countries on the red list were slashed
and requirements for testing change
we'll be discussing all of that uh with
the man in the know the transport
secretary grant champs joining me in
just a few minutes time
but also this morning how to manage your
daily demons through exercise the former
rugby league professional jamie acton
will be joining me to tell us all about
his new fitness app which tracks your
mental well-being
but then a little later the strange
world will be coming famous during
lockdown at quarter to 10 i'll be
speaking to the winner of the 2020 bake
off peter sawkins and i'll be asking him
for a couple of his best cooking hacks
and it's friday the 8th of october
grab another jab the biggest ever flu
vaccine campaign begins as health chiefs
warned that hospital admissions and
deaths from flu
could double this winter
travel takeoff the government cuts
testing requirements and slashes the red
list to just seven countries
a winter of discontent citizens advice
warns that calls to their helpline have
increased by a third as benefits are cut
and the cost of living rises
it's hard work living on on a poverty
you know what i mean and that is what it
is it's first class poverty i was poor
before the pandemic nothing's changed
[Applause]
they've got the money in the bank but
human rights campaigners criticized the
takeover of newcastle united by saudi
arabian investors
[Music]
the shoes are back the wedding ring is
back
and i'm back in the good books let's go
return of the ring and british tennis
legend andy murray is reunited with his
wedding band and his smelly trainers
after they both went missing in
california
as for the weather it's going to be warm
for many of us today after a very mild
start in some places but the murky north
and the west will have some rain
[Music]
morning all senior health officials are
warning that there could be a surge in
the number of flu cases this winter
there are worries that this year will be
much worse with the majority of covert
restrictions being eased skies shingi
maruriki has our first report
vaccines never have they been talked
about more but how can they help keep us
safe in the coming months before winter
begins to buy
these medics are urging people to come
forward for a vaccination we haven't
spoken about as much this year
the flu
in our campaign that launches today
people are being encouraged to book
their injection as soon as possible to
protect themselves and their loved ones
modeling suggests hospital admissions
and deaths caused by seasonal flu could
be two times that of a normal year
the combination of rising covet cases
low immunity against the flu after a
year of social distancing and indoor
socializing for the festive period could
prove catastrophic for the nhs
that is why gps like dr sarah jarvis are
encouraging not just the
immuno-compromised but people young and
old to get a shot
people are congregating they're not
socially distancing in the way they were
last year which meant that there was
virtually no flu to add to winter
pressure the nhs always comes under huge
pressure in winter this year we may well
have high cases of flu we're adding
covert into the mix and we've got a huge
backlog of people far more people than
usual needing care because they didn't
have it during the first and second
waves when hospitals were closed to
anybody who didn't have covert
but who exactly can act on this call to
action
the flu vaccine is being offered to
those over 50
pregnant those with health conditions
residential care frontline health
social care workers carers and those who
live with someone who is vulnerable
one concern to address in the coming
months is the hesitancy which we've seen
curb kovijab take up among minorities
so you need
the government and the public health
messaging
um
to go into those communities more and
talk to people in their community
because we're sort of a multi-racial
multi-ethnic multi-dimensional society
you have to
and you have to address all those
different groups in different ways
the store supply and rollout of
kovitjabs has been vital this year
saving thousands of lives
now as the temperature plummets people
are being asked to take another
injection in the hope of saving
thousands more shinki marike sky news
pleased to say the transport secretary
grant chaps joins us once again on the
program mr schatz very good morning
morning
uh as always seems to happen when you
appear on the show i have a list of
questions on your brief as long as my
arm but but i hope we can start just
briefly on on that which we're hearing
at the flu vaccination program clearly
there are a lot of concerns about the
pressures that could be brought to bed
on the health service given restrictions
are pretty much gone covert is in the
community and and flu will be increasing
just how bad do we think things could
get
i think it's extremely important that
people um get their flu vaccination in
previous years we will have heard these
messages pre-covered and some people
thought well you know i'm usually fine
with these things this year is different
as your report suggested you've had
people not building up any immunity
because last year we were all split
apart so much uh because of covid
and then the obviously the twin threats
of both covid uh and flew means that
this year getting your flu jab if you're
in any one of the many different
categories you you showed there all over
50s vulnerable people people who live
with vulnerable people just go and get
the flu jab done you can probably get it
at the same time or similar time to
doing the booster job for people for
covert as well
some of those involved in in the health
service are suggesting we could see
deaths from flu rising as high as 60 000
well look i'm not a epidemiologist even
though we've all become our armchair
once through uh through the covid crisis
but we know the dangers of flu it's not
new that's pressures on the health
service every single year uh through uh
the winter months due to flu and yes
last year was really just an exception
to that because of people staying at
home so but we can all do something
about it and of course the flu vaccine
as that is that thing um so you know
when you get the call um please go and
get the jab as has been so familiar with
kobe kovid but now for flu as well
let's both take off our amateur
epidemiologist hats and move directly on
to your brief and of course a big
announcement yesterday in terms of uh
travel around the world just seven
countries now
left on the red list and some people are
suggesting however that we should still
be concerned about the possibility of
variants coming into this country and
perhaps seeding is is that not a major
concern of the government anymore
well you're right so it's a major step
forward um really the travel industry
which has been into this crisis first
out last in many ways has suffered
hugely that's a lot of jobs on the line
etc
when it comes to the safety aspect of it
we are still requiring a test we're
going to move that down from being a pcr
test the the expensive ones that you
have to send away to our lab to a
lateral flow test so that will help and
it will enable us to monitor things and
actually reassuringly if you come back
from somewhere you do a lateral flow you
get a positive
then you'll be able to get a free nhs
pcr test in the normal way and you're
back into the normal system but the big
difference of course now is we're
vaccinated and if we're having this
conversation this time last year no one
was vaccinated and that really makes the
change here
just in terms of the testing and the
move from pcr to lateral flow can can
you give us a date on when we might know
this of course half term is fast
approaching there are plenty of people
who might not be able to afford to get
away for a break if we're talking about
a requirement for a pcr rather than a
lateral flow test yeah that's right we
want to get this done for half term for
people i know my colleagues over at
health
and to a certain extent extend the home
office there the people who have to
implement this this change are working
extremely hard on getting this done uh
and so we anticipate having it ready uh
for the half term um and what a
difference it will make for people
rather than having to
do things like send off the test and
wait for the result as people will be
familiar with the lateral flow you read
it on the cassette there and then it
shows your result within a you know a
few minutes
and much much easier much
less expensive as well
just just very briefly when might we
expect that announcement then
uh in the coming days we know when
obviously the half terms coming up and
my advice to people would be um just to
to hold off you will need to book one of
the make sure that you've got a lateral
flow uh tester booked and you'll you'll
put the the reference number on your
passenger locator form before you come
home of course you can fill that out
whilst you're abroad in most cases uh
and of course another simplification is
and it's already happened you no longer
need to take a test before you depart
wherever you're coming back from spain
or uh wherever you happen to be back to
the uk you no longer need to seek a test
before you come here so that's a major
simplification because the big one we're
waiting for in november this won't be
for half term i'm afraid but the u.s
have said that they'll reopen to uh
british visitors as well of course
that's a very major air route the
busiest in the world do we have a
specific date on that just yet air
transport secretary i don't i've been
speaking to my opposite number i spoke
to the american ambassador a couple of
days ago they're still working through
the technicalities of that they've said
november uh to us and obviously we're
working very closely with them because
we would like to see that done so
families can reunite businesses can uh
get together
and you know people can go traveling
again so
we we think it's uh it's it's certainly
well due we're allowing americans here
we're recognizing their vaccines and i
should mention in this big change that
we're making today
another 37 countries
are also being recognized by the united
kingdom for their vaccination programs
so those people will be able to follow
the new rules which is you know just a
simple lateral flow on day two
to move to slightly more domestic
matters in terms of the the the
shortages that we have seen at petrol
pumps um the petrol retailers
association have accused the government
of not having the ability know the
capacity to command and control the
crisis we're 15 days in now to shortages
at the pumps can we put an end date when
are we going to be out of this situation
i understand it's different in different
parts of the country but it's still
pretty bleak down in this part of it yes
i mean government doesn't have the
option doesn't have the ability to
control um
i mean they're right we don't have a
commander control system over our petrol
fuel supplies and that's probably a good
thing what we do know is that in most
parts of the country i was up in
manchester midlands last week
this has ended now if you're in london
or the southeast those are the only two
the areas where we're seeing any
continued problems but even there we are
starting to see the pla supplies come
through i know the army are plugging the
gaps uh and just as an interesting
statistic actually uh compared with the
low point
about eight or nine ten days ago
and now there's twice as much petrol in
the four courts underground in the four
courts than there was then so
everything's back to normal by this time
next week
uh yeah i think we're we're right at the
the tail end of this um now and just
again i just repeat there was never
actually a shortage of fuel in the
country in the refineries and the
storage centers if if somebody says go
out and buy which is what the story we
we saw um then queues are inevitable
there's almost nothing a government can
do to stop that from happening we saw it
with toilet paper and i think the
retailers association would disagree
with you on that one and they would
suggest that you know there have been
people in the industry warning about
this problem coming down the pipeline
for for quite some time just in terms of
the reason that we're in this situation
and of course it is you know shortage of
drivers currently there's a backlog i
believe around about 54 000 hgv licenses
to process um the situation's been
exacerbated by strike action of course
what are we doing to address that
backlog and you know those those hdv
licensing would pretty much sort the
problem out yeah let me just actually
nail this entirely for you there are not
54 000 people raising licenses
there's three and a half thousand people
who have very recently within the last
week applied for provisional hgv
licenses all of the rest so 52 odd
thousand
are people who i've put in for renewals
or perhaps address changes the rules are
very clear you don't stop driving for
those reasons so if you if you've if you
happen to be an http driver you're
watching this and you've said that
you've moved address for example so
you're one of those fifty thousand uh
it's not a problem you can carry on
driving uh they will be returned to you
in in time they're processing mid july
right now as you say because of the
unnecessary strikes that were taking
place during covert at dbla it does not
stop you from driving so this is not the
reason for the
for the problem and actually if you want
to become an hgv uh driver uh be very
welcome the salaries have obviously
become a lot more attractive now much
more competitive um you'll actually if
you apply for your provisional license
find that turned around within four or
five days so um but please do apply
we're looking for hgv drivers in this
country of course as is the case
worldwide
another topic we need to to dwell on um
there have been hints that there may
well be changes to hs2 coming down the
pipeline perhaps
getting rid of part of the part of the
line going off or prioritizing the kind
of the east to west line what is the
truth of all of this and when might we
get a definitive answer every day that
we that goes past where we're kind of in
this limbo position you know someone
somewhere is going to be losing money
so so uh very simply uh of course we're
building uh hs2 on the west coast side
um we want to make sure we get the
benefits of uh high-speed uh trains or
extra capacity really uh from uh
birmingham uh to leeds as well um and
that means that given that these plans
were first hatched fifteen twenty years
ago even uh a lot has happened in the
meantime including northern power
including the conservatives getting
elected in 2010 at minister you know
this has been on you this has been on
you know conservative desks for more
than a decade yeah i mean these are this
is a multi multi-decade uh project of
course and
all i was going to say is
northern powerhouse rail that's the plan
to link up lots of northern cities uh by
rail midlands hub that's the plan to
link up um western midlands east
midlands so we just want to make sure
it's all properly integrated together
there's no point plowing on with a plan
invented in a in a different time and
delivered very very slowly so if
anything what we want to do is speed up
these benefits and find better ways to
to do it and connect uh
tell me when we're going to find out
about the stand minister yes i was going
to say timing wise obviously we've got
the spending review uh coming up
that is a big moment where the
government sets out its its plans in
this case for the rest of the parliament
uh i think it's during the 27th of
october to give you a precise date so uh
not long to wait until we're able to put
all of this into context
i'm just having a quick look over your
shoulders and i can't see a newcastle
united uh uh emblem anywhere there i
don't know if you're a fan but what do
you make of the takeover of the club i
understand that many people dislike mike
ashley but muhammad bin salman you know
and his involvement in the death of
jamal khashoggi which our intelligence
services certainly seem to believe is
the case does mean that we have
some very unsavory people coming in and
taking over one of the biggest football
clubs in the country what do you make of
it
well first of all i mean there's a very
clear test actually it was called the
owners and directors test
for
football clubs and for the premier
league which they have to satisfy before
anybody can invest in take over uh a
club
they're not human rights experts though
are they
no no they're not of course look the
premier league um will need to and has
assessed this the owners and directors
test is the key thing and the point i
was going to make is that tracy crouch
who is an excellent mp was a sports
minister is actually carrying out a
review into this whole issue of finance
ownership and the rest of course if
people pass that test as the rules and
the law stands people are entitled to
investing clubs my understanding in this
case is there's been a complete
separation between the country and the
business that's involved
in so that there's no direct control
i have to confess you're not on my area
of complete expertise but i do know that
the owners and directors test has to
have been passed otherwise this could
not have taken over and i did know the
fans and seemed pretty uh pleased about
it when i when i saw them celebrating on
the on the tv last night
they certainly did uh yeah i don't know
whether that was just the announcement
or the fact we're getting closer to the
weekend uh grant chaps good to see you
this morning i certainly got through a
few questions there thanks for joining
us thank you
now still to come on the program this
morning uh fears of a growing diplomatic
ride between france and britain over
fishing rights
half past i'll be talking to the chair
of the european parliament's committee
on fisheries
[Music]
by past dates i'll be speaking to the
south african high commissioner and dame
irene hayes from hayes travel as those
restrictions are released
and at half-past we're just mentioning
it there a deal to make newcastle united
one of the world's richest football
clubs i'll be speaking to sports lawyer
trevor watkins about what the saudi
arabian takeover
[Music]
citizens advice say that calls to their
helpline have risen by a third as the
cost of living rises and benefits are
cut sky news is following the lives of
three families who all face a difficult
winter ahead uh let's bring in our
people and politics correspondent nick
martin who joins us now and nick just
tell us a little bit about the reporting
you've been doing the families that
you've been following
yeah good morning neil you know a few a
few months ago we saw
to try and spend a little bit of time
inside
factors that are swirling around the
family were having
on people and it's come well it
culminated in a report and today and
when you look at the impact that rising
energy costs rising fuel costs rising
food costs rents and things like that
have on families it really is quite a
shocking thing and we spent time with
families a couple called jackie and
jason in buxton another couple called
robert and laura and a single mum helen
who works part-time as a postie and they
are all absolutely struggling the bills
are stacking up around them and today's
piece starts with jackie who's
been working just before the pandemic
she lost her job just as it started she
was nursing her mum who was very ill
and now things have really started to
fall apart and this is this is what
jackie had to say when i stood in her
kitchen the other day and really things
weren't going very well for her at all
it's hard work living on on a poverty
you know what i mean and that is what it
is it's his first class poverty
i was poor before the pandemic nothing's
changed nothing's going to change that
is exactly how i feel and boris johnson
just doesn't help i can't even watch the
news and listen to him anymore it's
absolutely soldier
and then he's going on again today about
a higher wage and where is it it's going
to take a few years we're still going to
be on the bread line earning nothing and
living on nothing just paying your bills
they will have lost nick there uh so we
will thank him
well they can't hear me but we are very
grateful uh you can watch nick's full
special report struggling britain that's
at half past 11 this morning and then
throughout the day here on sky news
some of the day's other stories now
and a leading environmental group says
the government will miss its target of
net zero on greenhouse gases by the year
2050. the wwf claims that plans will
fail unless tougher restrictions are
imposed on big businesses
climate experts say there is a lack of
racial diversity in climate change
decision making the university of
bristol says men of color made up five
percent of contributions at local net
zero meetings while women of color
accounted for just two percent
despite making up 16
of bristol's population
as we always do let's take a quick look
at the impact of the climate on the
planet ah interesting up at the top
there uh that top line shows how our
power is being generated it's been
running 25 30
it's up to 58 from fossil fuels this
morning then you have the rise in global
temperature since records began the line
beneath that the time we think it will
take to get to a global rise of one and
a half degrees celsius seen by many as
the point of no return for the planet
and then you have total co2 emissions in
millions of tons
uh there have been some well very
different reactions to the takeover at
newcastle united by saudi arabian
investors while fans celebrated outside
the grounds the deal was condemned by
the fiance of jamal khashoggi the man
whose murder american officials say was
ordered by a senior saudi arabian prince
skies sports correspondent tom parmenter
reports
they haven't won a game in the premier
league this season but newcastle united
now have the victory they've craved
i've always questioned whether i would
see them win anything in my lifetime
but now i've got belief just means the
world football is this city simple as
the home oh my best day in my life
better than better than me ben being
bored to be fair
wonderful
it's not the money we care about it's
the ambition we want someone to look
forward to you know we want a team of
tries
they had that in the 90s when the goals
flowed the team sparkled and they all
loved it
but then came mike ashley who managed to
suck the joy away from this club
finally they can say that the mike
ashley era at newcastle is over that's
why they're here but also to try and
take in what comes next huge investment
dominated by money from saudi arabia
it puts them on a footing with the
richest clubs on the planet
i wasn't even alive when we were
challenging for the champions league and
when we were last in europa league i was
only six
and uh
i just went with some of them time for
myself
and
i just want the club to be something i
can support i believe in the premier
league say they are satisfied it would
be the saudi-backed consortium
controlling the club not the kingdom of
saudi arabia
and that their owners and directors test
on transparency and a clean financial
plan have been there tv thanks for all
the wonderful support
thank you thank you very much
amanda oh no well it was all about you
guys now it's all about you
premier league football is the best in
the world
uh and newcastle united is the best team
in the world and we want to see it get
those trophies obviously
at top of the premier league in europe
but to get trophies it means investment
patience time
and we want everybody just to
work with us to build the club to what
it needs to be
promises have been made about who will
be involved but the saudi arabian
investment fund is overseen by crown
prince mohammed bin salman the man the
united states accused of approving the
murder of journalist jamal khashoggi
it is a real shame for the new newcastle
and for the
british
english football day
that they have
now the football club
owned by a person who
responsible
the murderer of jamal
on time side they do care where the
money comes from and who owns their club
but they needed change
and the saudi-backed consortium were the
only ones offering to deliver it
tom parmenter sky news newcastle
uh let's see how the weather is looking
on this friday as we head into the
weekend uh pleased to report it's gonna
be quite warm over the next few days but
the north and the west will have a
little rain
uh today starting very mild for october
perhaps close to record-breaking for
scotland ireland and northern ireland
uh the morning's low clouds and fog over
england and wales will lift to leave
plenty of sunshine but the south east
for its part will remain dull the odd
light shower possible there elsewhere
rather cloudy with outbreaks of rain
heavy in places it will be warm for many
and breezy in the west
central and southern england will have a
cloudy afternoon whereas southern and
eastern scotland the east of ireland and
south east england should turn drier and
brighter
some very good news this morning we've
been reporting here on sky news how andy
murray had lost his trainers
but also his wedding ring which he
touches to them whenever he plays well
the former wimbledon and olympic
champion was in the bad books after
those shoes and the ring went missing in
california when he left them outside
but after andy appealed for help on
social medias both his trainers and the
ring were returned to him and he posted
the smelly moment on social media
a huge thanks uh for all the messages
and also to everyone for sharing the
story about the the shoes and the
wedding ring
um
had to make a few calls today and chat
to the security at the hotel and
everything and
a little update for everyone
would you believe it
they still absolutely stink but the
shoes are back the wedding ring is back
and i'm back in the good books let's go
lucky boy andy lucky boy uh still to
come on the program this morning and the
fears that a row over fishing rights
between france and the uk could lead to
elects electricity supplies being cut
off we'll be speaking to a french mep
next
[Music]
the best innovation comes when there is
a need and a problem to solve
rarely have we faced a more testing time
join us live from yorkshire for the
first in a series of sky news in-person
events where we will explore how to fire
up uk business watch thought-provoking
discussions with sky news experts on
building a stronger and greener economy
think big with us big ideas live on sky
news
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back uh senior health officials
are warning that there could be a surge
in the number of flu cases this winter
with predictions that hospital
admissions could double compared to a
normal year a little earlier the
transport secretary grant sharps called
on people to get vaccinated
i think it's extremely important that
people
get their flu vaccination in previous
years we will have heard these messages
pre-covered and some people thought well
you know i'm usually fine with these
things this year is different as your
report suggested you've had people not
building up any immunity because last
year we were all split apart so much uh
because of covid
and then the obviously the twin threats
are both coveted uh and flew means that
this year getting your flu jab if you're
in any one of the many different
categories you you showed there all over
50s vulnerable people people who live
with vulnerable people just go and get
the flu jab done you can probably get it
at the same time or similar time to
doing the booster uh jab for people for
covert as well
i also spoke to the transport secretary
about the changing travel rules with so
many countries being taken off the red
list asked grant chaps whether a
decision on relaxing the pcr test rule
in time for half term would be taken
soon
in the coming days we know when
obviously the half terms coming up and
my advice to people would be um just to
to to hold off you will need to book one
of the make sure that you've got a
lateral flow uh tester booked and you'll
you'll put the the reference number on
your passenger locator form
ali fortescue joins me in the studio
morning ali what did you make of the
transport secretary well i thought it
was interesting to him saying that in
the coming days we're going to get an
announcement on pcr tests for travel
because that's really important for
families that's been one of the big
questions when will they scrap the pla
the the rules at the moment are that you
have to get one of those expensive pcr
tests on day two after coming back
there's lots of pressure from families
and from the travel sector for that to
be scrapped in time for half term which
isn't far away at most schools on the
22nd of october he said that's going to
happen in the coming days but he also
said my advice would be just to hold off
so i think a bit of confusion still
around that and we heard him there too
talking about
the flu
vaccines this winter obviously that's
going to be an enormous logistical
challenge for the government getting
everyone jabbed not just for covid but
for flu as well we know that having both
viruses at the same time really
increases your risk of having serious
symptoms or of dying so um it was it was
i thought he sounded quite optimistic um
perhaps not taking it as seriously as
some would like him to he said the
pressure on the health service is there
every single year and that we're in a
different position now because so many
people have been vaccinated for covet
ali more from you throughout the show
for now thanks very much indeed
well let's return to those fears that
arrive over fishing rights between
france and the uk could lead to
electricity supplies from across the
channel being cut off french fishermen
are calling for better access to uk
waters i'm pleased to say that joining
us now is french mep pierre carliskind
chair of the european parliament's
committee on fisheries uh mr carlskin
good to see you this morning um
for viewers on this side of the channel
who might not be as as closely involved
in this dispute as as you and your
colleagues just explain the nature of
the dispute between the uk and france at
the moment
oh the nature good morning first and uh
happy to be with you this this morning
the the nature of the dispute is uh
is simple in fact we are implementing
the biggest ever cooperation agreement
between eu and any other country and
this is the same for for uk and
specifically on the beneficiary issue
we have negotiated during the years
after the decision of brexit and what is
in the agreement is that
we share
the waters the uk waters and the eu
waters so our fishermen can come to uk
waters and your fishermen can come to eu
waters but to access a specific zone the
territorial waters they need licenses
and we are just asking the
application the perfect application of
the treaty meetings that we are asking
to the uk government and to the jersey
government to give the licenses as it is
said and written in the treaty and right
now we're still waiting nine months
after the conclusion of the brexit we're
still waiting for um dozens of these
licenses so fishermen some french
fishermen can't do the activity anymore
yeah just in terms of the numbers i
think the uk announced last month just
12 of the 47 applications it had
received from french small boats had
been had been granted the jersey
government said that of 170 license
applications 75 had been rejected so
it's it it's your contention at the
british government uh the authorities on
jersey are are doing this
as part of the negotiations
yeah
what we are waiting is to
i mean
we have been uh collecting data i mean i
say we it's the french administration uh
mostly and the the european commission
has given the data
i mean the position data of this vessel
because you have to prove and this is
normal that uh fishery occurred uh in
the last years i mean we are not going
to
send new boats fishing in the
territorial waters of uk because we
don't want to and this is the this is
the agreement but we gave the data
showing that these ships these boats are
used to have
fishing activity in these waters so
we've worked seriously we've worked
seriously and what i understand is that
the uk
administration
uh not at the political level they just
don't understand why political level ask
them asks them
more
data more precision
i'm afraid that this is a way for boris
johnson
to divert from the current issue related
to brexit but
one thing is clear is that
nobody will have a better life in the uk
if you try to make
a life of the fishermen harder in france
this doesn't work like that and this is
really not useful to try to uh
give
troubles to french fishermen to get i
don't know why i don't know why i don't
understand what bruce johnson is trying
to do except for sorry sorry
but sorry to interrupt but some would
someone would say
by way of counter that the
proportionality of the french responses
is off the scale to threaten to cut off
energy supplies you know in regards to a
dispute over fishing seems well at the
very somewhat
yeah well
first
no electricity has been cut uh so far so
you still have the electricity and the
uh there's no recreation it's been
threatened more than once now you know
yeah
there's death threats they are
threatened but do you have to
understand that nine months later
some fishermen
haven't been
fishing during this last nine months
so some of them are a bit nervous you
have to understand that and from the
french part when we see that
the official position of france and from
europe
is insulted by the behavior of the uk
government once more we're not fighting
against the united kingdom this is a
great country and we fully understand uh
what uh
that you are a sovereign country but we
just do not accept that the uk
government outlawed that there are
threats but right now we haven't still
officially published any
potential retaliation measures these
measures there are written in the
agreement so we will activate them if we
do not succeed in discussing seriously
and politically and frankly with the uk
government so so far there is nothing
that is applied there is tension in the
air you have to understand that but we
we have to figure out what we can do to
have the the treaty fully and correctly
and frankly uh implemented
pierre carloskins good to see you this
morning thank you very much for joining
us sure
now nhs staff say they're under as much
pressure now as they were during the
peak
of the covid pandemic the organization
nhs charities together say that most
staff believe the strain on services
will continue for years skye's betty
cottle has been taking a look
coronavirus was the hardest thing many
nhs workers had ever faced but they knew
the backlog of non-covered patients
would be another battle
one they're now facing
this unrelenting workload and the scenes
inside hospitals during the pandemic
have taken their toll
the number of patients how sick they
were and the fact that they're all
fighting for breath
and they're all just there in front of
you um it's really difficult being there
in person it's the same everywhere so a
lot of my colleagues have struggled to
process and like you said go through
things and emotionally it's very
difficult
and they're worried about what's to come
81 of nhs staff say they are as
concerned about pressures on the service
now as they were at the peak of the
pandemic
and a huge 96 think the strain on
hospitals and other medical providers
will continue for years
and frontline workers are suffering
two-thirds have experienced mental
health problems since the start of last
year including anxiety and depression
many are only able to get therapy
because of donations to charities
it's really vitally important that we
continue to be there for ourselves and
through the nhs in the long term
because kovid has worsened
everything you know every challenge
there is within the nhs has been
impacted and worsened by kovid
doctors and nurses were healed as heroes
for the stress and sadness they endured
but as the rest of society gets back to
normal the nhs is still overwhelmed and
as winter approaches and waiting lists
grow staff are trying to treat as many
patients as possible but at what
personal cost
becky cottrell sky news
time for a look at the sport here's
hannah
ah record breakers me too
world's slowest dog
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by the vitality running world cup
[Music]
andy tell us a little bit about what you
guys do here and how you're trying to
make heading the ball safer for
everybody so we've developed a training
platform designed to help players learn
how to head the ball in a step-by-step
process designed by uefa pro coach easy
way for a licensed coaches all of the
steps that you should take to safely add
the ball
the system itself if you're using in
training you're doing two things with
one you're reducing the number of
impacts and the other one is because of
the realism of the system you're still
able to increase the skill level that
the players develop
what we're trying to say is if there's
10 headers a week that you're allowed to
do now we can help maybe give you 200 a
week
how mobile can you be do you need to be
in your house and it's totally wireless
you can use it anywhere like your
bedroom you can use it out in the garden
or you can use it in a living room and
that's going to be teaching you how to
head a ball better and you said before
that you weren't great at so we'll by
the end of the day we'll have you
walking out and scoring worldies if you
can like smooth out this 50p head we'll
see what we can do where am i here by
the way this is just our training center
we're not going to replace anything
we're there to complement what's
happening at training grounds already
all you've got to do is the ball's going
to come out of that circle and you've
got to head it straight back in so it's
like infinite head tennis oh
there you go
feel free to move around plant your feet
again if you want to just get
comfortable and just get used to heading
the ball recent research has come out
that shows that players are more likely
to suffer with conditions like dementia
about three and a half times more likely
we're seeing versus the general
population now that's been linked to
heading the ball so it's obviously an
issue from a player welfare point of
view and it's something that authorities
are starting to take very seriously if
you put power in it will come out back
at you faster
and if it spins it will challenge you a
bit harder as well so it's trying to get
you to put the ball right down the
middle of that circle right people have
been looking into this for about 20
years now the last 10 years the research
has really started to ramp up and we're
seeing real life stories now with the
likes of dennis law and terry mcdermott
there's that piece around player welfare
that the authorities just have to take
seriously they have to look at
mitigation strategies trying to reduce
heading probably in training which is
where we can control it much more
it's probably a sensible place to start
i mean i've not counted how many you've
done in this but i'm pretty certain
there's a lot more than you would do in
an average training session straight
away yeah a lot better than it would be
in average transition as well well there
you go that's because we're basically
planting you in the right formation
delivering the ball right to your head
yeah 21 in a row which is pretty good
notice the trajectories are altering you
have to move your body a lot more now
[Music]
morning
i'll join later
uh hannah thanks very much indeed uh
coming up after the break i'm going to
be hearing from the environmental group
wwf
we claim the uk is on course to miss
its target of net zero emissions by 2050
find out why next
[Music]
it's been an incredible journey having a
public-private partnership working
together with funders
with the governments and the ministries
of health in south africa
estrogeni and mozambique we
set out on a journey to eliminate
malaria in our region and for the last
six years have been quite successful in
being able to bring down the number of
cases as well as the number of debts
within the region and we we're not far
away from elimination so it's quite an
exciting time for us
it's a it's a absolute historic
announcement
the world has been waiting for the first
announcement of a malaria vaccine and
and this announcement
of the gsk rtss malaria vaccine
is is particularly important
it it
allows us to add an additional tool into
the arsenal that we have
particularly at a time when
malaria progress has plateaued
since since 2015.
of course even before the pandemic we
were behind the curve with our ambitious
goals for 2030 so bringing on a new tool
adds adds new energy new vigor for us to
get over the line um as as planned we
need to
to put that into context we certainly
believe it has the potential to save
tens of thousands of children
both from cases and death per year but
but the context is that it's got to be
used in combination with the existing
tools that we have and and that's a very
important
fact to consider it has to be used
both with the vector tools so that is
the tools we use against the mosquito so
our bed nets or our indo-residual
spraying program and it's also got to be
done in conjunction with diagnostics and
therapeutics so ensuring that the
children have access to healthcare is is
part of the package that the vaccine
works pretty well with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
they'll be a very mild start to friday
with some rain in the north and west
england and wales will see early low
cloud and fog lifting to leave plenty of
warm afternoon sunshine but parts of the
south will stay dull the odd shower is
possible elsewhere it's going to be
rather cloudy with outbreaks of rain
heavy in places the southwesterly flow
will bring clean air from the atlantic
so the air pollution index where one
means low pollution and 10 means very
high will stay low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now environmentalists say the government
is unlikely to meet its commitment to
reach net zero greenhouse gas emissions
by the year 2050. the wwf say the target
will be missed unless tougher
legislation is imposed on big business
uh joining now to discuss katie white
from the wwe katie i do hope you're well
good to see you this morning um just
just explain given that we're you know
the best part of three decades away from
the 2050 day
why we can say that we're not currently
on track for it
well the government has got an ambitious
target that will reduce our emissions by
two-thirds by 2035
and businesses are a core part of that
so we've taken a look at the biggest
businesses in the uk
and we've disappointingly found that
only 19
have got a plan to reach net zero now
more of them have got a target and
that's welcome that we've got a target
but obviously what's really important is
that you've got a plan to meet that
target and as i say only 19
have made that plan and we can see that
plan so what we're calling for is the
government to to stop the gap and and
not expect that they're going to get
these emissions reductions unless we
have legislation for plans and mandatory
transition plans
why then do you think at four out of
five 100 companies are are proving so
reluctant to come up with a with a
concrete and detailed action plan you'd
have thought that even just for reasons
of corporate social responsibility and
with all the eyes on green issues these
days that might be an idea to put
something down on paper
yeah i mean look in the run-up to the
landmark cop conference that we've got
coming up in glasgow in only a few weeks
time we've got businesses falling over
themselves to talk about net zero and as
i say there is a lot of commitments out
there but commitments are one thing a
plan is a very different thing you know
i compare it a bit like to a pizza box
there's calories on a pizza but it
doesn't mean to say you're going to stop
eating it or lose weight a weight
management plan is a very different
proposition and so whilst we do welcome
the companies that have come forward
with net zero commitments there are over
a quarter left in the foot so you
haven't and we'd urge them to come
forward with commitments we're also
saying we need that plan a government
needs to step in the window for
voluntary action has gone we all know
that the science is terrifying we've all
got to step up now and make sure we're
on that trajectory towards net zero with
credible plans alongside those credible
commitments
katie do you think it's likely however
that you can persuade this government
given its political inclinations um
to pursue to legislate to force
companies into doing this particularly
when you know other g7 nations well
certainly not all g7 nations are do are
doing what you're asking for
well i think to be fair the government
is saying this is their big issue so if
this is their big issue and they're
putting a plan on the table and they
want everybody to to put you know to
come on board and support them doing
that they need to set the criteria in
place and so we need legislation to make
sure there's a level playing field and
actually some of those leading
businesses are saying please do it
because at the moment
we're all in this sort of no-man's land
with various commitments of different um
ambition levels and actually we all want
to move together if we move together you
know not only is that good for the
climate but it could be really good for
the uk there's a lot of business
opportunities for those who go first and
go fastest
yeah and certainly that's something that
boris johnson particularly has been
banging on about over the past a couple
of years since he became prime minister
i just wonder then what do you need to
hear um from the leaders at the cop 26
summit as regards kind of you know
private the the private sector to kind
of get us towards that 2050 target
so first of all i want to hear from the
government i really want to hear from
the government and it has to be from the
top of government whether that's the
prime minister the chancellor or the
business secretary saying we are going
to be introducing legislation
for mandatory plans they've said already
it's going to be mandatory for these big
companies to say what they're emitting
these big companies punch above their
weight in terms of profit and in terms
of carbon emissions as they've said they
want to make sure they've got their
calories on the pack so to speak but
what we're saying is they have to say
it's mandatory for them to have a plan
to make sure that they all know the
direction of travel and they have to
come up with some credible action to
match up with those commitments we've
seen lots of this you know uh we've seen
shop windows people talking about their
net zero commitment we see it on packs
but what actually matters is the
reduction in carbon emissions because
the planet isn't bothered about the pr
the planet is bothered about the
reductions in emissions so we want the
government to come forward and do that
and we welcome more companies to come
forward with their commitments but most
importantly those plans to follow
through
uh katie aside from those comments about
pizza which i felt were directed
straight at me i was wondering whether
you were watching me pig out last night
thanks very much for joining us katie
white from the wwe